[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now as we
continue to fight covet 19 many people
have questions about the vaccine like
can your workplace make it mandatory i
spoke with eric palacios and associates
the sponsor of this next segment to get
answers eric welcome back
good to be here always good to see you
and talk about the important topics
happening around the world like
copen19 vaccinations a lot of people
wondering what happens when your
employer
or if your employer makes it mandatory
that's a touchy question and the answer
is
they can according to a memo from the
department of justice
your employer can request that you get
vaccinated
well is that legal though depends
on certain factors but for the most part
uh
it is uh courts in texas and also in
indiana
uh where employees have filed suit
against the companies they work for
have both ruled that they can either get
vaccinated or
look for work elsewhere wow and this is
what people
are definitely afraid of who aren't
vaccinated or who are refusing to do so
um you know are there any exemptions
that people should there are
okay there's two main ones uh the first
one is
if you have an underlying condition
which makes it dangerous for you
to be vaccinated uh then you need a
medical note and you can be
exempt from this requirement if your
boss is asking you to get a vaccine and
the second
exemption is for religious reasons if
your religious
beliefs don't allow you to get
vaccinated then you can also
refuse to get a vaccine based on this
now let's bring it to las vegas locally
here
are our local employers giving their
workers a choice
uh most are some companies even though
they're requiring
uh vaccinations uh for instance uh would
win
uh properties mgm properties and
according to
announcement by the governor this week
even state employees
are going to be required to be
vaccinated but if they choose not to
uh they can provide weekly negative
covet tests and still be allowed
to work so that's appreciated that this
accommodation has been made for those
that
cannot or do not want to get vaccinated
absolutely i'm sure people appreciate
the options well we will definitely
keep up to date with you on all of this
we're seeing developments daily so it's
going to be a hot topic for the weeks if
not months to come
absolutely okay well we will keep in
touch with you eric thank you so much
for joining us
we'll see you soon see you soon great
advice there thank you eric palacios and
associates for sponsoring this segment
for more information
give them a call at 702-444-7777